[Aplausos]
[Música]
esta es la pregunta del millón de
dólares porque putin quiere una guerra
abierta en ucrania o al menos porque
putin quiere que la otan piense que
quiere una guerra en ucrania puede
parecer novedad pero seguro que pocos
habríais darme una respuesta clara
pensando así rusia está en un momento
realmente malo las cosas como son
podemos decir que llevan en una crisis
económica por lo menos desde la invasión
de crimea y eso ocurrió en 2014 y cuando
hablamos de crisis económica tenemos que
pensar en una auténtica debacle con
episodios cercanas a la hiperinflación a
todo esto hay que sumarle las sanciones
económicas que todavía siguen presentes
y el hecho de que entrar en guerra
abierta con ucrania supondría perder a
casi todos los clientes que tienen de
gas natural
en visual político hemos hablado mil
veces de la dependencia que tiene europa
del gas ruso pero esa dependencia tiene
otra cara europa también es el mejor
cliente de rusia de poco sirve tener
enormes reservas de gas natural si no lo
puedes vender y finalmente tenemos la
guinda del pastel el coronavirus por
mucho que rusia sacará a su vacuna la
sputnik v su economía también ha sufrido
la pandemia dicho de otra forma la
economía rusa no está para muchos
riesgos pero además porque ucrania es
decir que puede ganar putin que puede
ganar rusia controlando ucrania recursos
naturales
poca cosa y en este país riqueza
empresas para nada ucrania es el país
más pobre de europa dicho de otra forma
lo haría mejor putin en centrarse en sus
propios problemas en su propio país
durante estos días seguro que habréis
oído toda clase de explicaciones de lo
más rocambolescas algunos llegan a
comparar a putin con el protagonista de
alguna telenovela venezolana uno de esos
hombres celosos que le dice a su mujer
si no eres mía no serás de nadie pero
seamos claros la política internacional
es mucho más compleja que todo esto y
ojo no os vamos a engañar aquí en visual
político no somos precisamente los
mayores fans de vladimir putin sí es
cierto que en algún momento lo hemos
tenido como mascota del canal o incluso
hemos hecho un montón de chistes sobre
él pero cualquiera que nos conozca sabe
que somos bastante anti putin ahora bien
esto no significa que ahora vayamos a
hacer argumentos de hombre de paja así
que en este vídeo vamos a explicar cuál
es la narrativa y las razones reales que
rusia está esgrimiendo para justificar
una posible guerra y lo vamos a hacer
porque en editorial aparte somos
independientes este canal no está
financiado por nadie más que nuestros
patrios y nuestros anunciantes no todos
los canales de youtube y todos los
medios pueden decir lo mismo y por
cierto que si queréis formar parte
activa de la comunidad visual política y
queréis apoyar este proyecto os recuerdo
que tenemos nuestro patrón no sólo
podréis colaborar con este proyecto para
que siga siendo independiente sino que
además recibiréis un montón de regalos
exclusivos como merchandising o nuestra
newsletter semanal de análisis político
si os interesa tenéis todos los enlaces
en la descripción pero sigamos con
nuestra historia porque la pregunta que
nos hacemos es qué interés tiene rusia
en ucrania de verdad son legítimas sus
razones para arriesgarse a entrar en una
guerra que le preocupa realmente a
vladimir putin hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos a
ver un poco de historia
[Música]
nación rusa
una veces habéis preguntado de dónde
viene la palabra rusia pues viene del
llamado antiguo rus que fue una
federación de tribus principalmente
eslavas y dónde creéis que tenía la
capital del antiguo rus moscú-san
petersburgo pues nada de eso la capital
estaba en kiev la actual ucrania
o dicho de otra forma podemos decir que
los primeros rusos de la historia bien
en buena medida de la actual ucrania el
antiguo bus llegó a ser el estado más
grande de toda europa sin embargo en el
siglo 13 los mongoles al mando de
patrick han de escribir a esta
federación y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos pero este cuento visual
polític nos remontamos tan atrás en el
tiempo
pues por dos razones la primera porque
es importante que entendamos el papel
que juega ucrania en la identidad rusa
de hecho todo lo que os estoy contando
ahora está sacado literalmente de los
discursos de vladimir putin paréntesis
si algún ucraniano se siente ofendido o
piensa que estoy diciendo alguna
inexactitud histórica y esto es
solamente la narrativa cosas la segunda
razón por la que nos remontamos tan
atrás en el tiempo es porque tenemos que
entender que ucrania como entidad
nacional es un país realmente joven
quiero decir el territorio que ahora
ocupa ucrania ha estado poblado por toda
clase de etnias y ha formado parte de
toda clase de imperios de hecho el
propio nombre ucrania viene de otra inah
que en ruso antiguo significa periferia
para que os hagáis una idea en el año
1569 buena parte de este territorio
pertenecía a la mancomunidad de lituania
habéis oído bien hoy en día a lituania
es un país relativamente pequeño pero
por aquellos años lituania abarcaba casi
todo lo que es ahora mismo polonia y
parte de ucrania eso explica que la
nobleza y las élites fueran de religión
católica pero la zona de crimea sin
embargo era mayoritariamente musulmana
estaba ocupada por los famosos tártaros
que por cierto paréntesis no tienen nada
que ver con la salsa tártara por si
alguno lo iba a buscar en google sin
embargo al menos según la narrativa rusa
la gente común en estas tierras hablaba
ruso y profesaba la religión ortodoxa
principalmente en los cosacos los
cosacos eran otra etnia más de las
muchas que vivían por aquí y estaban
cada vez más hartos de la nobleza
lituano polaca así es como estalló una
guerra contra la mancomunidad de
lituania y así es como en el año mil 686
quiet pasó a control lo sacó toda la
zona controlada por los cosacos se
llamaba malo rusia es decir la pequeña
rusia los cosacos se integraron
enseguida en la nobleza rusa y durante
siglos miles de ucranianos emigran a
rusia como si fuera parte de su misma
patria para que os hagáis una idea uno
de los novelistas más importantes de la
cultura rusa es nicolás gogol escribía
el ruso toda su vida sin embargo nació
en la actual ucrania pero esperado
momento porque vamos a avanzar al siglo
20 y todavía nos va a costar encontrar a
alguna entidad nacional a la que podamos
llamar ucrania de hecho tras la
revolución bolchevique el mapa estaba
así
como podéis ver en este mapa hay una
parte que si pertenecía a la unión
soviética pero todavía había regiones de
lo que ahora mismo consideramos como
ucrania que en aquel momento estaban
dentro de polonia o dentro de la antigua
checoslovaquia de hecho cuando se creó
la unión soviética la república de don
tías quería formar parte de la república
rusa y fue lenin vladimir lenin quien
decidió que pasará a formar parte de la
nueva república democrática de ucrania
que a su vez estaba dentro de la unión
soviética dicho de otra forma que la
ucrania que hoy en día conocemos surge
después de la segunda guerra mundial ahí
es cuando rusia decide que parte de los
territorios conquistados entren a
engrosar al territorio ucraniano y no el
ruso y grace pero porque no querían que
rusia fuera más grande pues lo cierto es
que por aquel entonces la frontera entre
rusia y ucrania importaba más bien poco
pensando bien ambos países formaban
parte de la unión soviética ambos
estaban directamente controlados desde
moscú ambos tenían cultura y tradiciones
rusas y ambos formaban parte de un mismo
pueblo eslavo todo lo demás era
accesorio
ah
sin embargo en el año 1991 ucrania se
independizó y eso a rusia no le hizo la
más mínima gracia según la narrativa
soviética fue rusia quien reagrupó
distintas etnias y regiones y las
unificó en torno a un concepto nacional
único de repente después de que todo
esto ocurriera llega a los ucranianos y
deciden independizarse nos parece
injusto pues si puede ser el problema el
problema es que este mismo argumento se
podría aplicar para infinidad de países
que también fueron colonizados que
creéis que la india existía antes de que
llegaran los británicos pues
evidentemente no antes de la
colonización británica el territorio de
la india y de pakistán era una amalgama
de reinos y de tribus de repente
llegaran los británicos y lo unifica con
todo dentro de una misma colonia años
más tarde los habitantes de esta colonia
se independizaron pero mantuvieron más o
menos las mismas fronteras coloniales
digo más o menos porque hubo bastantes
guerras pero eso es otra historia para
otros vídeos sin embargo creo que pocos
justificarían ahora mismo que españa
reclama se colombia a estas alturas
alegando no sé qué razones históricas
pero la pregunta la auténtica pregunta
es
a estas razones históricas son lo que le
preocupan a putin pues no del todo ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
y realmente importa
rusia tiene miedo de que la otan coloque
misiles balísticos apuntando a su
frontera peor aún rusia tiene miedo de
que la otan coloque cabezas nucleares
apuntando a moscú y diréis en serio pero
si la otan ya tiene cabezas nucleares
pues si tenéis razón tanto a la otan
como rusia tienen arsenal nuclear y
misiles balísticos apuntándose el uno al
otro ahora bien no es lo mismo tener un
misil balístico en el oeste de alemania-
es decir a 2.000 kilómetros de distancia
de moscú que tenerlo en la frontera con
ucrania que está a 700 km en otras
palabras rusia no quiere que la otan
tenga países miembros en su frontera
pero ojo no penséis que los rusos son
unas pobrecitas víctimas de la otan
ellos tienen una base militar gigantesca
en kaliningrado de la que por cierto ya
hemos hablado aquí en visual polític que
hace frontera con polonia y con lituania
y ya os podéis imaginar todo el arsenal
militar y los misiles que tiene que
haber por aquí tenemos que recordar una
cosa muy importante la otan es una
alianza militar creada con el firme
propósito de defenderse contra la unión
soviética es decir que es el antagonista
número uno de la actual rusia por
supuesto en los años 90 firmaron una
especie de declaró de paz y prometieron
que nunca harían ejercicios militares
cerca de rusia sin embargo desde
entonces la otan no ha dejado de
expandirse hacia el este
en este mapa podéis ver como en el año
1999 entraron polonia hungría y
república checa- en 2004 entraron en los
países bálticos rumanía bulgaria
eslovaquia y eslovenia vamos que cada
vez están más cerca de rusia y esto
desde la óptica del kremlin es toda una
traición y una maniobra agresiva pero
por supuesto desde la óptica de la otan
la historia es muy distinta porque son
todos estos países quienes
voluntariamente decidieron unirse a la
unión y que queréis que os diga tiene
bastante lógica que quieran formar parte
de la otan pensando bien todos ellos son
países que fueron invadidos por la unión
soviética y que quieren escapar de la
influencia rusa es lógico que quieran la
protección de eeuu y del resto de países
europeos y eso explica que por ejemplo
todos los edificios oficiales de un país
como lituania tengan banderas de la otan
junto a su bandera nacional y su bandera
de la unión europea
y diréis pero no exageran un poco porque
tienen tanto miedo tanta paranoia con
una invasión de rusia pues si podríais
tener razón el miedo a una posible
invasión rusa podría parecer exagerado
hasta el año 2014 cuando putin demostró
que era muy real si amigos de visual
político 2014 fue el año en el que putin
invadió la península de crimea y apoyo a
los separatistas del este de ucrania y
lo hizo porque simplemente ucrania quiso
hacer un pacto de libre comercio con la
unión europea
[Música]
y cuál ha sido la reacción de ucrania
pues en cierto modo podemos decir que
rusia ha perdido bastante con esta
invasión no sólo hablamos de las
sanciones a la economía rusa es que
además el apoyo a la otan se ha
disparado en casi toda ucrania los
ucranianos no quieren volver oír hablar
de rusia salvo aquellos que viven en las
regiones del este es decir en el llamado
donbass y ahora la pregunta que muchos
os estaréis haciendo espero y porque
ahora en 2022 putin quiere volver a
tocar los tambores de guerra que pasa
exactamente en este momento pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
pillado con los pantalones bajados
rusia ha colocado a más de 100.000
soldados en la frontera con rusia que
están armados hasta los dientes hay
incluso tanques y artillería pesada y
llevan en esta zona desde otoño de 2021
para que os hagáis una idea esto es la
cuarta parte de todo el ejército de
ucrania al completo como ya hemos visto
en anteriores vídeos de visual político
ucraniano es capaz de resistir un ataque
ruso a gran escala si es verdad desde el
año 2014 el ejército de ucrania se ha
modernizado y ahora tienen armamento y
entrenamiento de eeuu y de europa lo que
antes era un ejército corrupto que ni
siquiera tenía cómo vestir a todos sus
soldados ahora es algo mucho más serio
ahora bien sin un refuerzo de la otan es
casi imposible que resistieran a un
ataque a gran escala de la madre rusia
por el momento a duras penas se han
movilizado tropas y no está claro que
todos los miembros de la otan estén
dispuestos a hacerlo
así que rusia ha aprovechado la
situación para escribir su carta a santa
claus habéis oído bien en diciembre de
2021 la embajada rusa presentó sus
demandas ante la casa blanca es decir
sus condiciones para empezar a negociar
una hipotética retirada de esas tropas
que habían estacionado y bien digo eso
era una carta santa claus es decir una
serie de peticiones que son
prácticamente impensables entre otras
cosas rusia exige que la otan no acepte
a nuevos miembros pero no sólo eso
también pide que la otan no vuelva a
hacer ejercicios en países del este
dicho de otra forma rusia quiere decirle
a una serie de estados soberanos lo que
pueden o no pueden hacer con sus
ejércitos dentro de sus propias
fronteras nacionales recordad que no ha
habido prácticamente ningún soldado de
la otan en ucrania pero no sólo eso
rusia sólo quiere negociar con eeuu es
decir que dan por sentado que la otan no
es un interlocutor para el resto de
estados europeos que forman parte de la
alianza no tienen el más mínimo interés
para putin al menos por ahora aunque de
esto hablaremos en los próximos vídeos
porque ya os adelanto que el tema de
ucrania va a tener muchos episodios aquí
en visual político si no os queréis
perder ya sabéis suscribiros y darle a
la campanita para que o si hay una
notificación cuando actualizamos pero
vamos a seguir con nuestra historia
porque ahora las preguntas son que
quiere putin exactamente con estas
demandas
[Música]
i
pensadlo bien esto es una apuesta muy
arriesgada una apuesta arriesgada como
pocas básicamente rusia está demostrando
que está dispuesto a atacar ucrania
total o parcialmente no sólo eso está
demostrando que tiene recursos
suficientes como para hacerlo y está
poniendo unas demandas totalmente
maximalistas para sentarse a negociar
con eeuu con la otan la pregunta es es
este un pretexto para justificar una
guerra a estas alturas creo que nadie
tiene la respuesta pero es difícil de
pensar que a rusia le interesará una
guerra abierta podría ser una forma de
testear hasta dónde está dispuesta a
llegar la otan esta hipótesis tiene más
lógica tal vez pueda servir para mejorar
su postura negociadora pensadlo así no
tiene sentido que rusia quiere invadir
ucrania al menos toda ucrania la mitad
del país se revelaría contra el invasor
y sería una guerra de desgaste larga y
tediosa y ya sabéis cómo terminan las
guerras de desgaste largas y tediosas y
si no ya le podéis preguntar a bailén
con su experiencia en afganistán sin
embargo no sería descabellado pensar que
putin quiere a partir ucrania en dos
mitades es decir que las regiones del
este ya sabéis túnez y luhansk lo que se
considera el llamado tumbas se
conviertan en una república satélite de
rusia
que la mayoría de la población en estos
sitios es rusoparlante no es una idea
del todo descabellada por otro lado no
sería la primera vez que ucrania cambia
sus fronteras de nuevo pero todo esto
son especulaciones así que ahora turno
para vosotros que creéis que veremos en
ucrania llegaremos a ver guerra abierta
llegaremos a ver un nuevo mapa de
ucrania con las repúblicas de demi así
luhansk siendo un país independiente y
dentro de lo que cabe satélite de rusia
o tal vez la otan será capaz de frenar a
vladimir putin podeis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
político sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a este canal
y darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]